within your identity as a self you have  all kinds of roles that are somehow  contributing to that identity but are  not equivalent to that identity  yeah  i wonder if like my two hands have  different  because there's a different experience  to me picking up something with my right  hand  and then my left hand  so are those like uh  that's a really cool question lex are  they certainly feel like their own  things  and but that could be just uh  anthropomorphization based on cultural  narratives and so on  it could but i think it's a legitimate  empirical question because it also could  be sort of ian mill gilchrist stuff it  could be  you're using different hemispheres and  they sort of have different agent arena  relationships to the environment this is  a really important question in the  cognitive science of the self  does does that hemispheric difference  mean you're multiple or you actually  have a singular self  you